et on en parle avec nicolas vidal
rédacteur en chef de putsch médias merci
d'être avec nous nicolas vidal bonjour
bon bienvenue sur le plateau de rtl
france alors on viens de l'entendre
encore une fois de nouvelles
arrestations niveau des jeunes qu'est ce
que ça vous évoque
pour l'instant c'est vrai que les
cortèges sont compliquées a fait du
moins c'est compliqué à gérer par parle
par le pouvoir en place parce que les
manifestations se répète en permanence
on a eu la guerre la grosse
manifestation on a aujourd'hui le gilet
jaune vous le savez je crois que le
problème beaucoup plus large
effectivement que ça on a une
mobilisation énorme en ce moment à paris
factuellement il ya eu beaucoup de monde
plus de monde du moins dans les rues que
le 7 janvier moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
les calicots les slogans les bannières
les retraites aux flambeaux
donc ça veut dire que mouvement social
on le dit à un rassemblement il continue
il perdure il s'étend surtout donc
alléger les jeunes te dis souvent que la
grève générale ou la grève la
mobilisation contre les retraites n'est
que le format xxl des légendes donc
aujourd'hui c'est de soixante troisième
acte je crois mais mais ça les réponses
ne sont toujours pas apporté et je pense
que aujourd'hui on a du grain à moudre
depuis hier notamment avec vous le savez
un david le conseil d'état qui vient
d'avoir rendre un avis extrêmement
sévère sras réforme des retraites donc
léger les jeunes la réforme des
retraites tout ça est un tout mais alors
justement cette cette décision du
conseil d'état est ce que c'est pas une
sorte de pas en arrière pour le
gouvernement
alors c'est sûr que c'est une énorme une
énorme épine l'une est très très très
grosse épine dans le pied du
gouvernement parce qu'on ne peut pas
dire que le conseil d'état soit une
piscine bolchévique ou une officine de
radicaliser le conseil d'état comme son
nom l'indiqué conseil l'état donc il dit
je le lis rapidement parce que c'est
toujours important de savoir ce qui a
été dit c'est qui le consultaient estime
ne pas avoir le temps de garantir au
mieux la sécurité juridique de la
réforme et déplore des projections
financières lacunaire plus de recours
aux ordonnances qui fait perdre la
visibilité vous imaginez que c'est quand
même un avis extrêmement compliqué pour
le gouvernement c'est un peu pour moi la
série béni
où les chefs de l'exécutif des exécutifs
ministre et député tente depuis un mois
et demi d'expliquer les tous les
bienfaits de la réforme mais on se rend
compte que finalement le conseil d'état
vient là avaliser les normes troubles
qui a pris une partie la population je
crois a raison ça cette réforme des
retraites et et qui continue qui fait
perdurer les manifestations et la
mobilisation sociale qui est importante
tant qu est très importante
alors ce projet de loi de réforme des
retraites sera examiné également mi
février par l'assemblée nationale
mais c'est vrai que du coup on a
l'impression que le gouvernement ne va
pas pouvoir mener à bien ce projet de
loi de réforme de retraite
en plus de cette contestation populaire
qu'est ce qui va se passer concrètement
dans le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
on le dit depuis un certain temps mais
je crois qu'on est vraiment dans une
impasse politique parce qu'il suffit pas
d'expliquer aux gens qui sont débiles
qui n'ont rien compris la réforme des
retraites
il ya un moment donné il va falloir
faire quelque chose de simple qui est
constitutionnel
quand vous avez un on va dire une casse
d'un pacte social depuis 45 on le répète
en permanence les retraites c'est le
pacte social de 45 quand vous arrivez à
un an et demi une mobilisation deux
gilet jaune maintenant la réforme des
retraites il ya une question simple ou
une solution simple la bonne vieille
solution du référendum de manière à
mettre tout le monde d'accord
cette réforme des retraites parce qu'on
l'a dit ici mais c'est une c'est une
c'est une réforme finalement
qu'idéologique c'est pour ça qu'elle est
mal ficelé c'est une vraie force
idéologique donc elle est mal ficelé l
effet la ville concède et à la teste
également et la question se pose la
question centrale est ce que cette
réforme néolibérale qui pour moi duo
libéral vous fait-elle société est ce
que le modèle néolibéral futile société
aujourd'hui et est ce que le new delhi
mais néolibérale c'est une question que
je pose d'un est ce que le modèle
néolibéral est il compatible avec la
démocratie
la seule réponse david c'est de poser un
référendum une fois pour toute et de
voir ce que les français on pense et je
crois qu encore plus maintenant après
l'avis du conseil d'état
vous pariez de référendum c'est l'une
des revendications principales des
jaunes du coup comment les gilet jaune
se place vis-à-vis de cette réforme des
retraites
ben vous savez j les jeunes et les
grévistes et on voit toutes les
professions avocats médecins toute une
série profession je vais pas tous les
énumérer c'est pas que l'egypte
l'échangé des jeunes qu'on a bien voulu
caractérisé depuis de longs mois on est
vraiment face à un mur sociale le
problème c'est que les gilets jaunes
régie de nombre ont proposé le rythme et
le rythme n'est que l'émanation du
référendum de la volonté souveraine du
peuple a décidé de l'avenir c'est très
simple à partir de là emmanuel macron a
fait sa sortie fictivement sur la
démocratie dictature
moi je crois qu'il faut simplement
régler le problème je le répète un haut
risque mais ça au référendum pourrait
pourrait éluder tout problème tout
trouble tout soupçon il faut moment
donné se baser là dessus les jeunes
avaient commencé à évoquer l'idée parce
qu'avec la partie de souveraineté de
décision d'aider les gens à réduire
l'attrait peut ni ce n'est pas les
grands plateaux
cette idée nous en appareils attaque ce
gaz est là car ce gasoil enfin toutes
ces choses mais ce qu'il y avait en
sous-main en soubassement c'est vraiment
cette volonté du peuple par décider de
son avenir
voilà il s'agit crois que c'est
absolument centrale
63e acte des gilets jaunes 52e jours de
protestation contre la réforme de
retraites 70% des français qui sont
favorables à la poursuite de cette
mobilisation
comment vous expliquez que le
gouvernement soit aussi décrié ce qu'on
peut parler de record au niveau de la
constellation prestation populaire bien
entendu parce qu'on arrive toujours au
même point de clivage
on est sur un projet de société
néolibérale qu'un emmanuel macron en
septembre 2010 cette part de
souveraineté européenne
il ne parle plus de souveraineté
française et comme ces orientations de
politique économique je le répète une
nouvelle fois sont indiquées par lego
paix les grandes orientations de
politique économique de l'union
européenne
finalement on a l'impression que la
place de la démocratie de la voix du
peuple de plus en plus restreinte donc
emmanuel macron un projet néolibéral qui
met en place allocations chômage gel du
smic réforme des retraites on prend
encore un site et si la plus grosse
mesure à la demande des retraites c'est
là où le problème il ya le point de
clivage est le point de pivot et un
moment donné il va venir falloir je
crois que la seule sortie c'est ça mais
si je repose la question est ce que la
société néolibérale ou un projet
néolibéral et qui fait tilt société
c'est à dire qui il va pouvoir mettre en
accord une majorité de français est il
compatible et démocratie c'est une
question que je pose je crois que le
référendum pourra vous répondre
merci beaucoup d'échos la menace d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de putsch
poids médias